il roule la nuit dans les rues de paris
tous les vendredis soirs les adeptes du
roller se donnent rendez vous pour de
nouvelles sensations sur le bitume
alors petite balade sur roulettes avec
isabelle dupont et françois cartier
embarquement pour la planète roller la
grande boucle parisienne sur les petites
roulettes traditionnelle promenade du
vendredi soir
il y as mis ton qu'une quinzaine
d'accrocs du patin on lance l aventure
depuis le roller s'est américanisée
perfectionner et la mode apple reste les
promenades hebdomadaire attire désormais
entre 50 et 100 personnes tous âges et
niveaux confondus
chacun à son rythme pour un tour de 20 à
30 km
passage obligé devant les hauts lieux de
la capitale histoire aussi de remédier
au petit incident de parcours
là on a eu un double problème de
chaussettes
il ya un petit bout de caoutchouc qui
s'appelle la chaussette la chaussette
est là elle a trouvé donc double
problème de recettes
heureusement on a réparé
montparnasse trocadéro saint michel un
voyage de nuit entre 10 heures et une
heure du matin
leur idéal et le moyen rêvé distille
pour découvrir autrement de la capitale
c'est aussi cela leur plaisir à dijon
n'a pas la possibilité de faire du
roller comme ça je suis très heureux
découvrir paris ce soir la nuit on
n'appartient plus à la ville c'est elle
qui nous appartient on l'a on la prend à
nous on va où on veut quand on veut
il ya beaucoup moins de pollution et on
est vraiment tranquille du roller
touristique qui n'empêche pas de
s'offrir le plaisir de quelques
acrobaties sur la plus belle avenue du
monde